- Per Gridiron Heights guidelines,
the best team in the league runs the town hall.
- OK, go ahead, Josh.
- No, the Eagles have the best record.
- Really?
- Are you sure?
- It does feel like we're the best, though, right?
- Order, order!
- We're gonna follow my very easy schedule.
There've been some complaints that this season has been weird...
Two XFL quarterbacks are starting.
Geno Smith is a star.
And people are actually enjoying themselves in the New York section!
- ♪ ♪ ♪  I wanna be a part of it...
...East Rutherford, New Jersey! ♪♪♪
- I'll now open the meeting up to concerns.
- We need a town curfew. I'm thinking, like, 4:30.
- Wait, I have to wear a helmet after my ride is over?
- Hey, everyone, recycle your quarterbacks.
- It's not that f--king hard.
- I don't like how suddenly we're all waking up with aches and pains...
...and how we all thought we could outrun Father Time forever,
but now he draws ever closer with each tick of the game clock.
- Expand the rushing lanes.
- I'm not here to make excuses.
I wrote 'em all down before I got here.
- OK, unless there's any other—
[Doors busting open]
- You all thought you could meet up and kick me out.
Well, I've got all your pets, and I'm gonna—
- This is just a normally scheduled town hall meeting.
- Oh, well, then I guess I'll just sell these back to you, then.
- Why should I have to direct traffic? People should just know where to go.
We shouldn't have to work when it's spooky season.
If other QBs are better, then why don't they debate me?
There's just a lot of pressure to be...
...as awful as the guy who had my position before me.
And another thing!
It is f***ing bulls**t that the Rodgers Rate isn't real.